ça rien avoir de quoi quand tu appelle à
la grève il faut savoir ce que tu es en
train de faire
bien sûr que la grève est légitime mais
tu es en train de punir des gens qui
demandent juste à lui travaillé pour
1300 bas comédien au cinéma dans le
quartier ils prennent parti pour
infiniti dire je suis toujours prêt à
finir pour ce qui est des retraites
c'est pour ça qu'ils oublient chacun et
chacun les hommes ne connaissent pas la
fois on pourra changer les comédiens eux
sont des intermittents je te dis une
chose c'est un comédien pays boos
souvent quand il est jeune quand il a 65
ans en me disant il bosse plus voilà les
sépare alors vous le dis on va pas le
payer si on est pas
bref ces jeunes personnes aux abords il
parlait de cali
c'est sous une tension media ag c'est
vrai on trouvera d'ailleurs le gala de
l'union équipes enseignantes visées
n'ont été pour finir si vous n'avez pas
lu la tribune libre dans le jdd dimanche
type est de vider les salles
et justement notre boulot est de nous
est vrai nous vraiment de nous ruiner
boulot mature et juge à vous battre
mottier jeu mais la raison j'avais juste
des petites gens comme nous juste comme
nous mais l'audience fait parler des
grèves et tu m'as dit fait 222 casser la
gueule dans la rue une fois sur le gilet
jaune
je vais donner mon avis sur 10 ans les
gilles et jean effectivement moi j'étais
plutôt contre un moment mais on exige
est sorti par l'arrière de 2 d'ici part
de ventes mais ce qui l'attendait devant
et on m'a dit sur des réseaux sociaux
ferme ta gueule tu es un riche mais tous
d'où tu viens avec de l'oseille on a
donné chair dans une banque comme à
donner de l'argent etc et quand
j'entends des gens comme toi qui lis
être un métier se faire maquiller de se
faire applaudir des gens et choisir il
est fou c'est que nous l'avons eu
vraiment tu me laisses va vous laisser
parler oui ou blessés par ici vous plaît
vraiment tu peux pas dire il ya plein de
gens c'est un manager et moi infirmières
ya plein de gens qui souhaiteraient
faire rêver de maintien mais elles sont
vides inférieures elles ont choisi cette
affaire mais appuyé le donner il ya la
fin de la galère des infirmières je suis
d'ivoire jeu puisqu'une affirmé alors
qu'une attraction que tu tries normale
d'institutrices iata il ya plein de gens
moi pas voir ma fille est peut être
institutrice et l attrait des deux
métiers bah non non non pas du tout
médecin alors y'a plein de messages ont
convenu samedi d'abord pompiers ont mis
les policiers sur c'est un rêve d'être
profité pour s'y voir ça au clavier ça
que je parle au nom mais je verrai des
presses et soulager lé camp nou langer
les chéris ya plein de gens qui rêvent d
maintenant songer à décoller il ya
boucher y avoir des débouchés c'est ma
passion c'est six ans il s'est calé à
dévaliser le premier animateur de télé
maintenant inimitiés yari megadeth crise
en syrie les dépressions mais je vous
avez cité continue la passion du boulot
c'est les artisans et je les sais c'est
que 40 maisons pêche de travail arrêtée
je suis pas contre la grève entamée
radim dans sa tuque décridibilise aussi
tous les gens qui sont ici et qui
bossent et ben tu dis d électro c'est
pas un vrai métier les électrodes
l'étude ne maquille les dénaturer je
sais pas parler des maquilleurs les
applaudir les maquignons non on n'avait
jamais cessé le travail pour dommages et
par les [ __ ] journée mais certains
désordres mentaux les scieries hier que
jeanine les paye tous les jours et oui
madame et 4h vraiment le fun
quatre heures les électro les
maquilleurs mais il travaille parce
qu'aussi ya une émission et parce
qu'aussi on est autour d'elle bien sûr
les autres latin mais cyril organiser ce
grand barnum de la télévision ça cette
émission et puis c'est pas parce qu'un
fou rire la journée pour préparer
l'émission il faut juger les motards il
n'est pas dans là il n'est pas maquillée
pas dans les mrc pas un animateur
comédien d'affaires dans le veston
micropieux plus version gratuite est son
micro parce que tout le monde a le droit
de s'exprimer
raymond tu en train de dire par ailleurs
je vais prendre gaga qui fait l'émission
voit que je regarde tous les jours que
j'aime vraiment c'est une bonne émission
préférée à la télé c'est que vous étiez
en train de dire que valérie bègue n'a
pas vrai travail pas des noms mais là où
je te reproche quelque chose là c'est de
monter les uns contre les autres
je suis parvenu non par ben moi il n'y a
pas de hiérarchie dans les métiers
d'antan où le monde tout le monde
travaille alors il écrit des métiers qui
sont plus pénibles que l'autre lui peu
des métiers qu'on a envie de plus de
faire que d'autres des métiers qui sont
des métiers passion et des métiers qui
sont des métiers raisons peuvent
d'accord ça j'ai longtemps mais de dire
que par exemple nous on serait des
sortes de fainéants qui lui mérite on
pas d'avoir une retraite qui ne méritons
pas ceci ou cela c'est pas bien de faire
ça parce que tout le monde travaille
après effectivement il ya des gens qui
travaillent avec qui ont beaucoup plus
de chasse calme et du coup j'ai eu un
métier que moi l'aventuré américaine
aventure et pour nos chers juste je vous
dis ça réagit de ouf sur les réseaux ou
là dessus vraiment je vous le dis c'est
la police pour ça que je continue avec
peu le débat parce que là vraiment les
gens sont comme des fous sur la réaction
aux crises pour avoir des réactions en
direct s'il vous plaît sur twitter parce
que c'est un aj énormément restent
calmement à valérie tu sais très bien
que je t'adore c'est très bien mais tu
as dit tu as tout dit il ya des métiers
passion il ya des messieurs raison quand
tu décides de faire de ta carrière
un métier passion pendant 50 60 70 ans
et qu'à 70 ans tu dis merde j'ai pas de
retraite
fallait y penser avant il ya des gens
ils vont au boulot en métier raison n'a
pas le choix c'est pour bouffer et
m'insérer qu'affirme ya c'est une
passion elle crainte de maladie mais
parce que j'ai un deuxième retrait c'est
ce que j'ai à te dire ça c'est la
réforme des retraites ça il faut que
vous alors moi je n'ai pas à faire mieux
comprendre la réforme passion et raison
mais quand deux choses différentes
mon métier passion je le respecte c'est
bien c'est de la passion oui mais après
il faut pas me dire ouais c'est dur
c'est dur
déjà j'aimerais bien venir ici autour de
la table se faire maquiller prendre de
l'argent des terres ce coffret métal un
choix qu'on n'a pas entendu là-dessus
non énormément d'argent je suis je suis
assez choqué par et mon jeu extrêmement
méprisant méprisant et ça c'est cheval
on maîtrise un brave type mais là ils
extraient d'amour qui viens de dire est
intolérable et inacceptable alors à lui
des intermittents du spectacle donc son
pea pas maison épi sa vie et visité
mardi à sanaa c'est insultant ses
étudiants à temps et c'est y pas
d'emmener un mec qui vient ici dans les
émissions à 8 heures du matin qu'ils
reparlent une heure du matin l'emmène
pas avec toi lui en parlez pas des
intermittents des intermittents il
travaille non ils font les cons mais
parfois juillet août quand vous prenez
deux 2 mois de vacances ou en hiver la
touche n'est pas aussi ne convient pas
ils sont passés non le temps mais
intermittents avait plus vraiment à la
drh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non tu es tu les achats reinhardt
étonnant il méprise toujours les gens
que je sais quoi faire si je ne maîtrise
l'axone dernier un camion mais c'est
juste pour dire ah oui c'est juste pour
dire je n'y avait personne
et cette grève allait légitime et le
droit de grève est constitutionnel voilà
on n'a pas de sens et voilà alors cette
map assez belle manière sur les
comédiens je trouve ça intolérable de
leur laine en cible est-ce que c'est
effectivement parmi ceux les
intermittents et c'est internet un
intermittent comédiens un intermittent
comme une marionnette la dame un
décorateur normal comme que kakuta
lumière mais romain une connerie
monumentale monumentale à la deuxième
chose
le régime des retraites pour les
comédiens et poignante habitants c'est
une catastrophe
saluée junte birmane avait l'honore je
dis pas ça un verre intermittence
non non non très chouette du catastrophe
absolue parce que effectivement d'une
carrière de comédien ou même deux
cadreurs ou dans le cinéma quand tu es
maquillera tu peux bosser beaucoup au
début après plus jamais ça l'amplitude
donc tu fermes ta tu termines ou
danseuse à la raison tu termines avec
800 700 euros c'est intolérable
donc effectivement que les ont connus se
nouent et se mobilisent pour cette
course est très fort voilà c'est très
bien et on peut pas dire que ce sont des
mecs des nantis c'est pas vrai ils ont
pas d'éloges dans le cul cul dans birth
qui est mon cas pour le bon marché une
excuse moi j'ai vu mon père m'aide pas
chacun renvoie de chômage a pas pouvoir
m'en mené nulle part de pas voir beauf
et c'est donc arrête de penser que ce
soit 600 m dans médias point barre fut
son étude sur les marchés des cubes
pendant 42 ans les entraînements je suis
fait ça c'est une passion que
laissez-moi laisser ma part laissez moi
parler pas vraiment tu ne peux pas aller
mais non d'une munition là on respecte
ce qui a fait de la merde on respecte
sait ce qu'il fait des comédiens on sait
bien on doit être les autres sur les
autres
[Musique]